Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Du, der Trump hat jetzt den Golf von Mexiko umbenannt.
Ja, und wir benennen als nächstes Fucking um.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 514 vom 16. Februar 2025.
Die Wahlen nahen und wir unterhalten uns über Namensgebung.
Ja.
Wusstest du, dass Fucking gar nicht mehr Fucking heißt?
Nee, wusste ich nicht.
Fucking heißt jetzt Fugging.
Ich glaube, das war eine ökonomische Entscheidung. Denen wird doch andauernd
das Ortsschild gezockt.
Ja, genau.
Konnten sie sich einfach den Namen nicht mehr leisten.
Das war das Problem. Korrekt hätten sie sich ja eigentlich in Frigging umbenennen müssen.
Ja, das wäre dann, das hätte man nicht piepsen müssen.
Das wäre sehr lustig gewesen. Die Amerikaner sind ja überhaupt sehr kreativ, ne?
Ah, da gibt es auch ein Bier, was da herkommt, ne? Kennst du das Bier aus Fooking?
Nee, hast du es schon mal getrunken?
Habe ich nicht getrunken, ich
weiß nur, dass es es gibt. Es ist ein helles und es heißt Fooking hell.
Das ist natürlich naheliegend.
Ja, das ist in der Tat, oh Mann ey, großartig.
In Umbenennungen steckt auch eine ganze Menge Power drin. Aber ich weiß nicht,
vielleicht wäre Frigging doch wirklich ganz gut gewesen.
Ich weiß ja nicht, ich finde das irgendwie überhaupt so lustig,
wie die Amerikaner also mit ihrer Sprache da ein Paul machen.
Ich meine, wir sind ja da mittlerweile auch ziemlich weit.
Das muss immer alles ganz richtig sein, weil sonst das ist ja falsch.
Also dieses Auspiepen von fucking, was jeder sagt den ganzen Tag,
werte das hier alles nur sinnlos auf.
Den brinkanischen Podcast kann man teilweise gar nicht verstehen.
Wenn wir das machen würden, piep, ja, dann wäre es teufellos.
Ja, ich wüsste gar nicht, was hier alles piepen würde.
Dann habe ich gesagt, piep, habe ich gesagt.
Naja.
Fucking hell.
Kommen wir zum, also es ist ein Unterschied, diese hier mit den Begriffe wegpiepen,
und einfach Landstriche umbenennen.
Das ist übrigens, warum haben wir das mit aufgenommen? Weil es jetzt umgesetzt
wurde auf dem Internet. Im Internet.
Und zwar, und das ist eigentlich das Interessante weltweit.
Hast du da nicht sogar auch mal ein CAE zugemacht, dass sowas wie Google Maps
in sehr weiten, also es ist in eigentlich tausenden Varianten gibt, weil dann,
also weil es ja beispielsweise je nach Region der Erde Unstimmigkeiten darüber
herrschen, wo bestimmte Grenzen sind und das dann irgendwie man,
um dem Thema zu entgehen,
was weiß ich, türkischen Besuchern eine andere Grenze in Zypern zeigt als griechischen und.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, ob ich da einen Podcast zu gemacht habe,
aber das ist definitiv so.
Ich meine, Grenzen sind ja auch sagen wir mal Es gibt sehr unterschiedliche Auffassungen darüber.
Und ich meine, das hast du in Israel ist es ja schon hochgradig politisch,
wo da eine Linie gezogen wird oder nicht. und ob die gestrichelt ist und ob
ein Gebiet gestrichelt ist oder nicht und welches und welche unterschiedlichen Farben du da machst.
Und da gibt es ja auch genug umstrittene, offene Gebiete auf der Welt,
wo zwei oder mehr Parteien sehr unterschiedliche Auffassungen darüber haben,
wie legitim jetzt hier eine Grenzziehung denn ist.
Und so ist es halt auch mit der Benennung von Orten. Ich meine,
man kann natürlich auch sagen, wir verwenden auch andere Namen für andere Städte und andere Länder.
Dann kann man halt auch irgendwelche Gebiete so oder so nennen, ist mir doch egal.
Jetzt ist es halt in Amerika, der Golf von Amerika, ob der Golf von Amerika
heißt oder Golf von Mexiko, ist ja eigentlich auch egal.
Also ich kann dir sagen, das war mir mal egal. Das war mir völlig scheißegal,
wie der Golf von Mexiko heißt.
Ja, aber jetzt ist es natürlich ein Unterwerfungsinstrument geworden.
Jetzt ist es mir wichtig, dass der Golf von Mexiko...
Golf von Mexiko heißt. Das ist mir plötzlich wichtig geworden.
Das war mir vorher scheißegal.
Aber was bringt das jetzt groß? Also ich meine, jetzt werden ja auch schon dann
die Journalisten aussortiert im Presseraum im Weißen Haus, wenn sie nicht irgendwie
die richtige Terminologie benutzen.
Darum geht es ja eigentlich auch. Es geht um Ausgrenzen. Es geht darum,
Machtgrenzen neu zu ziehen und das macht man dann halt unter anderem über Sprache
und dann eben auch um solche Benennungen, weil das ist halt dann auch alles
irgendwie Politik mit anderen Mitteln. So läuft es.
Ja, okay, Golf von Mexiko Schöne Ecke Vor allem, wenn man sie vom südlichen
Ende besucht Nämlich von Mexiko Oder,
natürlich auch östlich Kuba, Havanna Alles Zugänge zum Golf von Mexiko Ja.
Wo ist eigentlich Fugging?
Na, wo ist wohl Fugging? Irgendwo in Bayern Nee Vielen Dank.
In Franken? Oh nein, jetzt gibt es Ärger.
Noch schlimmer, ist noch nicht mal in Deutschland. Ist in Österreich.
Oh, wirklich?
Im Bezirk Braunau am Inn. Ist ja auch gerade wieder sehr in.
Ist das wirklich ein österreichisches Bier?
Naja,
du hast ja gesagt.
Nach der österreichischen Ortschaft Fugging benannt, aber Markeninhaber ist
ein Berliner Bierverlag.
Deswegen können wir auch das Dorf umbenennen.
Ein Berliner Bierverlag.
Also das ist ja mal wirklich, das ist ja mal ein Wort, was ich noch nicht kannte.
Ein Bierverlag. man kann Bier verlegen.
Ein historischer Begriff für ein Getränke-Großhandelsunternehmen.
Wirklich? Wow. Das war mir neu.
Das liebe ich so am Podcasting. Man lernt jedes Mal was dazu.
Fucking hell.
Bier Verlag. Krass. Fucking hell.
Okay, machen wir weiter?
Okay, ausnahmsweise.
Jetzt wissen wir, es ist glaube ich das erste Mal, dass wir für ein Bier bei
uns auf ein Bier aufmerksam machen.
Meinst du?
Andere Podcaster sind Podcasts ja regelmäßig erkennbar betrunken.
Wir hingegen nur auf Pilzen.
So, dann Feedback.
Ich trinke hier gerade Soja, Milch, Kakao. Ist auch sehr hübsch.
Ja gut, das ist also ich meine, da brauchst du jetzt auch kein Mittlerz zu erwarten.
Wir haben Feedback bekommen.
Oh ja, Diverses. Genau. Ähm.
Erstes Feedback war von Daniela, die uns kurz korrigiert hat,
dass BSW hat mit der AfD und Union gestimmt.
Stimmt. Stimmt. Beim Zustrombegrenzungsgesetz.
Zustrombegrenzungsgesetz, ja. Also bei der zweiten Abstimmung sozusagen,
da wo es um das eigentliche Gesetz ging, was ja gescheitert ist.
Da hat tatsächlich das BSW mit sieben von ihren zehn möglichen Stimmen,
die anderen drei haben nicht abgestimmt, mit Ja gestimmt. Das habe ich in dem
Moment, glaube ich, übersehen. Ich glaube, ich hatte diesen Kommentar gemacht.
Sie hatten sich allerdings vorher bei diesem Entschließungsantrag enthalten.
Und hätten Sie da nicht abgestimmt oder dagegen gestimmt, dann wäre auch der
schon nicht durchgekommen.
Beides kann man, glaube ich, sinnvoll als Unterstützung werten, ja, und das haben wir,
also mir war das so bewusst, insofern wundere ich mich, dass wir es so,
dass wir es anders gesagt hätten, aber wahrscheinlich haben wir einen falschen,
Eindruck vermittelt, weil wir,
uns primär mit Friedrich Merz und der FDP auseinandergesetzt haben.
Ich hatte es, glaube ich, so gesagt, aber du achtest ja immer nicht drauf, was ich sage, von daher.
Dafür haben wir ja die Kommentare. Okay, also genau. BSW hat mit der AfD gestimmt
beim Zustrombegrenzungsgesetz.
Sieben von elf. Die anderen haben nicht abgegeben.
Ja.
So.
Und nicht abgegeben wird hier übrigens anders ausgewiesen als enthalten.
Also nicht mitgestimmt wird unterschieden von enthalten.
Ja, klar.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Weil das eine erhöht ja die Grundgesamtheit und das andere nicht.
Aha.
Interessant. Das heißt, wenn die nicht abgegeben hätten, wäre das Ding auch nicht verabschiedet.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht so genau, wie die Zahlen sind. Ich habe es nicht nachgerechnet,
aber es hätte, glaube ich, schon einen Unterschied gemacht.
Okay, also ja. Und ich denke ja, unterbelichtet das Thema BSW.
Bei uns sowieso. Wir setzen uns ja selten mit denen auseinander.
Nächster Kommentar ist von N. N.
Sagt, der Wahl-O-Mat kann tatsächlich auch mal hilfreich sein.
Mein Mann arbeitet mit Jugendlichen aus in erster Linie Finanz und in diesem
Fall leider auch sozial schwachem Umfeld, die dazu meist Lernschwächen haben.
Da verfängt das Gewäsch der Braunen. Da war die Überraschung groß,
dass plötzlich die Linke ganz oben stand.
Aber die Fragen, Aussagen mussten ihnen quasi alle erstmal erklärt werden. Dazu komplex.
Ja, vielen Dank für diesen Kommentar. Ich kann mir das sehr gut vorstellen,
dass solche Systeme in einer aktiven politischen Bildung und so deutlich jetzt
mal diesen Vorgang hier sehr wertvoll sein kann, definitiv.
Zeigt aber auch sofort das Problem auf, das zu verstehen, politische Inhalte zu verstehen.
Also überhaupt so dieses, hier, das ist das Problemfeld, wie soll ich mich dazu verhalten?
Politische Problemfelder sind schwierig. Ehrlich gesagt, ich merke das auch
selbst immer wieder hier bei uns.
Weil wann auch immer, was weiß ich, du kommst jetzt mit einem Thema an,
wo ich mich irgendwie vorher nicht so richtig eingelesen habe,
was ich nur so medial am Rand mitgenommen habe.
Und da merke ich immer wieder so, wie die Maschine anfängt zu rattern.
Was, wie, wo, wo ist da jetzt oben und unten, links und rechts.
Bis man also wirklich die Kraft und das Vermögen hat, klare Positionen zu beziehen zu etwas.
Erfordert einen Aufwand, einen Verständnisaufwand, Aufwand, den das kann man
den meisten Leuten noch nicht mal vorwerfen, weil ehrlich gesagt uns geht es
allen auch immer so, es ist halt irgendwie schwierig.
Diese ganze Debatte haben wir ja auch immer wieder beim Abstimmungsverhalten
im Bundestag und so weiter.
Ihr habt aber dagegen gestimmt. Guckt mal hier, das steht ja in der Datenbank und so weiter.
Die Realität ist, wenn da irgendein Gesetz beschlossen wird,
dann ist das in irgendeinem Ausschuss durchgenudelt worden.
Dann haben sich die Delegierten einer Fraktion, die in diesem Ausschuss sitzen,
dort eine Rolle spielen und wenn sie eine Mehrheitsrolle spielen,
dann eben sozusagen auch,
im Wesentlichen wahrscheinlich den Inhalt dieses Gesetzesvorhabens dann entsprechend
geprägt haben, dann wird denen einfach vertraut. Dann wird halt mit der ganzen Fraktion abgestimmt.
So, ja, die sagen das, das passt schon.
Ich kann mich da eh nicht so äußern, weil ich habe keine Ahnung über die,
was weiß ich, notwendige Renovierung der Infrastruktur des Wasserhaushalts irgendwie
in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland oder so, weil es ist nicht mein Feld.
Ich bin für Netzpolitik zuständig und so weiter.
Ja gut, aber das, also wenn ich da kurz, das ist richtig, so wird abgestimmt,
ja, das ist ja wahrscheinlich auch ganz, also das scheint ja noch ganz gut zu sein.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass wir jetzt nicht unbedingt bessere Ergebnisse
hätten, wenn alle irgendwie alle mal so abstimmen nach ihrem Informationsstand.
Insofern macht es schon halbwegs Sinn, dass man irgendwie Expertinnengruppen bildet.
Was ich glaube, was aber hier natürlich auch ein weiterer Aspekt des Problems
ist, das N hier schildert, dass die Sachverhalte komplexer sind,
als sie auf Anhieb erscheinen.
Ein Beispiel. Wenn der Robert Habeck sagt, er findet es nicht in Ordnung,
dass auf Kapitalerträge keine Sozialversicherungsbeiträge entfallen,
aber auf Arbeit.
Ja, dann würde ich das in erster Linie mal als richtig spontan wahrnehmen und denke,
dass es natürlich eine inhärente Bevorteilung der Kapitalisten ist oder derjenigen,
des Geldes gegenüber dem Menschen.
Und das ist ein grundsätzliches Problem, das ist das eine, glaube ich,
große Problem der kapitalistischen Gesellschaft, dass Geld, wenn man es lagert,
mehr wird und die Arbeitskraft des Menschen auf die Zeit gesehen einfach immer weiter abnimmt.
Das heißt, wenn der Arbeitnehmer einen Tag nicht arbeitet oder die Tagelöhnerin
für einen Tag nicht arbeitet, dann hat sie etwas verloren und das Geld,
was dabei gespart wurde, ist potenziell durch Zinsen mehr geworden.
Insofern sollte man natürlich den Ertragreichtum des Geldes,
der ohnehin schon höher ist, nicht auch noch durch das Ausnehmen von bestimmten Zinsen.
Bestimmten Ertragslagen oder steuerlichen Belastungen bevorteilen.
Gleichzeitig wird dann natürlich auch darauf hingewiesen, es gibt aber auch
eine ganze Menge Menschen, die ja gewissermaßen auch von ihrer Altersvorsorge
oder sonstiges davon abhängig machen.
Und dann wird das so diskutiert, dass es jetzt um die kleinen Sparer geht.
Ja, ich als jemand, der darauf blickt,
lese sowas nur am Rand und deswegen nehme ich das als Beispiel,
habe ich mich jetzt gar nicht mit auseinandergesetzt und denke bei beiden Argumenten
oh krass, yo, Moment mal ich kann genauso aus den Überschriften, die ich da.
Bekomme, einerseits den Schluss ziehen zu sagen, ah ja super endlich müssen
die Kapitalisten auch Sozialbeiträge zahlen oder was oder Oder ich kann mir denken,
oh, meine Güte, jetzt wollen die auch noch an die, keine Ahnung,
300 Euro Zinserträge, die ich im Jahr habe, ran und wollen wir da auch noch was von wegnehmen.
Beide Varianten werden da draußen verbreitet, je nachdem, welche Webseite du besuchst.
Und beide kurz dargestellten Varianten beeinflussen den Schluss,
den man aus der gleichen Meldung zieht, in unterschiedliche Richtungen.
Und man muss sich damit auseinandersetzen, um am Ende es zu verstehen.
Und das wird jetzt ja, das machen viele Leute nicht und das wird natürlich auch
nicht unbedingt beigebracht in Deutschland.
Politische Bildung ist jetzt nicht etwas, was in diesem Land einen großen Stellenwert genießt. Leider.
Ja, die politische Kommunikation. Wie hieß es so schön auf so einem schönen
Klaus-Steck-Plakat einst?
Deutsche Arbeiter, die SPD will euch eure Villen im Tessin wegnehmen.
Ja, so und das ist auch, also da muss man ja auch mal irgendwie...
Gut, wir haben noch sehr viel mehr Feedback, was vor allem noch sehr viel länger ist.
Jetzt werden wir erstmal gescholten.
Wir sollten vielleicht kurz sagen, von wem?
Ja, genau. Das wollte ich auch. Von Anke werden wir gescholten,
von Anke Domscheit-Berg, die wir ja auch schon zu Gast hatten,
hier bei Logbuch Nespolitik.
Ich habe die Nummer gerade vergessen. Was war es, die 100?
200.
Okay. Ja, stimmt nicht, die 100.
Anke war bei der Logbuch-Netzpolitik 200 unsere Sendungsgästin.
Eine unserer Sendungsgästin, genau. Möchtest du da eine Vorbemerkung abgeben?
Naja, also sie,
war ursprünglich mal Grünen-Mitglied, ist dann 2012 der Piratenpartei beigetreten.
Da hat sie, ich glaube, sowohl für den Bundestag als auch für Europa kandidiert, aber ohne Erfolg.
Sie ist dann 2017 parteilos auf der Landesliste der Linken Brandenburg angetreten
und auch damit in den Bundestag gekommen.
Und 2021 ist sie in die Partei eingetreten, nachdem sie den Listenplatz 2 bekommen hatte.
Also das hat sie nicht vorher gemacht, weil sie dachte, das hätte jetzt in einem
Kampf um den Listenplatz ja kontextualisiert werden können.
Und sie ist dann auch 2021 erneut in den Bundestag eingezogen und hatte jetzt schon vor einiger Zeit,
wenn ich mich recht erinnere, bekannt gegeben, dass sie nicht erneut kandidieren wird.
Das heißt, sie hat jetzt fertig.
Sie wird uns nicht noch mal im Bundestag vertreten. Und sie hat dort die ganze
Zeit immer, und das muss man glaube ich auch mal vorbemerken hier,
eigentlich immer die Position vertreten, in der Digitalpolitik auch vertiefend,
in den Ausschüssen, in denen sie saß, im Zweifelsfall, die wir hier auch genauso vertreten hätten.
Ja, das denke ich, kann man relativ klar sagen.
Das heißt, Anke ist auf Linie. Ja.
Und nein, muss man doch, also gerade wenn jetzt, also und,
Gerade, ich denke, das wäre mir nun mal wichtig, das dem auch vorauszusetzen.
Okay, gut. Sie schreibt, ich muss hier mal kritiklos werden,
denn ich finde auffällig, wie sehr ihr die Existenz und die Wirkung der Linken
in der Politik auslasst.
Und das ist in existenziellen Wahlkampfzeiten, in denen es ein linkes Gegengewicht
gegen Rechtsextreme im Bundestag braucht, halt auch nicht egal.
Warum erwähnt ihr nicht, dass
bei den Brandmauer-Abstimmungen die Linke konsequent dagegen gestimmt hat?
Warum erwähnt ihr zum Beispiel nicht, dass es ohne die Stimmen der Linken gar
nicht gereicht hätte, dass es ein paar Abweichler bei CDU und FDP gab?
Fakt ist, die Brandmauer wäre einfach gefallen ohne die Stimmen der Linken.
Von uns gab es 26 Stimmen gegen diesen menschenverachtenden Gesetzesvorschlag
und insgesamt gab es 11 Stimmen Mehrheit gegen den Gesetzentwurf. Entwurf.
Insofern habt ihr die Sachlage schlicht falsch dargestellt.
Und wenn man schon so ausführlich über das Thema redet, warum lässt man dann
weg, dass Heidi Reichenek die Vorsitzende der Linken im Bundestag die Rede der
Legislatur gehalten hat.
Eine Rede, die über 30 Millionen Mal in diversen sozialen Netzen geliked worden
ist und dazu beigetragen hat, dass seit Januar 20.000 neue Mitglieder der Linken beigetreten sind.
Inzwischen 19 Prozent der Jugend Linke wählen würden und die Linke bei 6% steht.
Das ist ja immerhin der Turnaround dieser Wahl und könnte mitten in der Dystopie
auch ein bisschen Hoffnung geben.
Gleichzeitig kackt das BSW ab, mit dessen Stimmen die Brandmauer eingerissen
worden ist bei der ersten Abstimmung.
Ja, mit den Prognosen, das ist ja immer so eine Sache, aber tatsächlich,
wenn ich das richtig verfolgt habe, das stimmt.
Also Umfragen sehen definitiv einen Aufwärtstrend bei den Linken. Das ist so, oder?
Ja, ähm,
Und auch, dass es bei den Jugendlichen so stark ist, macht ja auch Hoffnung für die ferne Zukunft.
Weil es sei denn, die werden dann, wenn sie älter werden, auch scheiße oder gehen für BSW.
So, jetzt gibt es aber nochmal extra Kloppe hier. Persönlich nehme ich,
dass ihr die Linke auch beim Thema pädokriminelle Inhalte im Internet komplett
ausgelassen habt. Die Texte, die ihr verlinkt habt zur Recherche und auf die
ihr euch bezieht, erwähnen alle meine kleinen Anfragen.
Seit Jahren bin ich an diesem Thema dran im Bundestag. Meine Nachfragen an Nancy
Faeser im Digitalausschuss haben überhaupt dazu geführt, dass sie versprochen
hat, das BKA mit Löschung dieser Inhalte zu beauftragen.
Dennoch in einer kleinen Anfrage.
Kurz davor hatte mir das BMI geantwortet, dass es dafür keine Rechtsgrundlage gäbe.
Es kann nicht sein, dass ihr nicht mitbekommen habt, dass ich ja als digitalpolitische
Sprecherin der Linken da wesentliche politische Arbeit im Bundestag geleistet habe.
Denn die ist, wie schon geschrieben, ja buchstäblich mehrfach in den von euch
verlinkten Texten erwähnt.
Nur ihr lasst sie weg. Und für Zufall kann ich das nicht mehr halten,
denn das ist ja auch nicht das erste Mal. Linus, haben wir eine Agenda?
Nein, also ich muss mal sagen, die Anke hat an dieser Stelle einen Punkt.
Wir haben das nicht hier hervorgehoben und es wäre gerade auch in dem Beispiel,
was sie nennt, durchaus angemessen gewesen, das zu tun.
Das kann ich jetzt erstmal nur grundsätzlich so sagen.
Es war keine böse Absicht, weil wir in diesem Podcast in der Regel sowieso selten
individuelle Politikerinnen loben.
Wir kritisieren individuelle Politikerinnen sehr klar, auch das zu einem Ausmaß, was,
von einigen auch nicht gutiert wird, wenn es jetzt um Friedrich Merz oder Christian
Lindner geht zum Beispiel.
Das ist das Einzige, was ich als Begründung nennen kann.
Aber vielleicht kann ich ganz grundsätzlich schon sagen,
dass wir im Kontext dessen, weil wir das bei kaum jemandem machen,
auch insbesondere Anke hier sicherlich über diese acht Jahre, die sie im Bundestag war,
wahrscheinlich selten nennenswert gewürdigt haben, an Stellen,
wo sie es verdient hätte.
Abgesehen jetzt in LNP 200.
Die 314 Folgen her ist und ich weiß nicht wie viele Jahre.
Stimmt auch.
Aber da muss man aber auch sagen, aber gut, dass du das nochmal benennst,
Weil ich glaube nicht, dass wir andere aktive Politikerinnen jemals,
doch hatten wir auch mal in der Sendung, kann ich jetzt schwer sagen, aber wir achten darauf,
bin ich jetzt vorsichtig, bei so vielen Sendungen haben wir sicherlich irgendwo
auch mal eine andere aktive Politikerin gehabt.
Ja, aber lies mal ruhig noch weiter vor, wir müssen jetzt nicht im Detail, oder?
Okay. So, weiter schreibt sie noch.
Ich habe bis jetzt nie Feedback dazu geschrieben, aber ich habe mich schon extrem oft darüber geärgert.
Ich betrachte mich nämlich als Teil eurer Community und war immer gern ihr langer
Arm im Parlament. Aus dem Chaosumfeld habe ich häufig Sachverständige in den Bundestag eingeladen.
Ich bin seit 2010 auf jedem C3 und bei jedem C3-Camp gewesen.
Eure Themen habe ich immer auch als meine und unsere Themen der Linken verstanden
und in diesem Sinne politisch im Bundestag vertreten.
Von Vorratsdatenspeicherung bis Chatkontrolle und trotzdem schweigt er das systematisch tot.
Als wäre es egal, ob es alle diese Anfragen und digitalpolitische Arbeit im
Bundestag gegeben hat oder nicht, ob die Sachverständigen der Chaos-Community
zur Anhörung eingeladen worden sind oder nicht.
Nach zwei Legislaturen verlasse ich jetzt den Bundestag und will das wenigstens
mal gesagt haben, denn ich bin menschlich und persönlich enttäuscht.
Und das könnte ja egal sein, was Einzelpersonen und ihre Befindlichkeiten schlicht
egal sind, aber in diesen Zeiten ist es eben nicht egal, welche Partei im Bundestag
für welche Positionen steht, in Bezug auf Brandmauern, rechte Themen oder auch,
digitalpolitisch und da habt ihr Verantwortung und die nehmt ihr nicht wahr.
Gleichzeitig über den Rechtsruckklagen und auf Faschos schimpfen wirkt dann
halt auch ein bisschen billig.
Man muss schon ein bisschen mehr dazu beitragen, den Faschismus zu verhindern,
auch als digitalpolitischer Podcast.
Das war mir jetzt auch wichtig, dass wir das auch nochmal besprechen, weil,
Ich glaube, da hat Anke einen wichtigen Punkt.
Wenn wir in den letzten Jahren, kann man sich jetzt darüber streiten,
wie einflussreich Oppositionsarbeit sein konnte in den großen Koalitionen, die wir hatten.
Also damit meine ich die starken, übermächtigen Stimmen, die sich da in einer
Koalition gebündelt haben.
Gleichzeitig ist die Opposition, sind das die einzigen, die irgendwie ein spürbares,
also im Bundestag in irgendeiner Weise dokumentiertes Gegengewicht zum Regierungshandeln darstellen.
Und da werden wir sicherlich auch unsere Positionierungen in den kommenden Jahren
oder unseren Umgang damit in den kommenden Jahren durchaus revidieren müssen.
Wenn wir sagen, ja, ob Opposition oder Koalition, wir diskutieren die Ideen
und nicht die Positionen oder die Parteien,
da werden wir uns Gedanken darüber machen müssen.
Und deswegen finde ich das, wollte ich das auch gerne hier mal,
also diese Kritik hier auch gerne mal so zum Ausdruck bringen,
weil es ist ja auch schockierend,
also was Anke sagt, stimmt ja auch einfach so und die hat das jetzt viele Jahre
im Bundestag gemacht und vertreten und.
Es klingt da ja jetzt eine gewisse Unzufriedenheit raus,
die Unterstützung aus der Community oder erweiterten Zivilgesellschaft angeht.
Und da werden wir uns vielleicht in Zukunft, und damit wir meine ich jetzt erstmal
uns beide, aber natürlich auch den,
was weiß ich, die gesamte progressive Bewegung oder was,
werden wir uns darüber Gedanken machen müssen, wie man quasi zu Parteien und
deren Hervorhebung oder nicht steht.
Deswegen danke für diesen Hinweis und auch den Denkanstoß, der damit für mich einhergeht.
Wir hatten ja bei LNP 26, gerade unsere Politikerin nicht eingefallen sind.
Wir hatten ja Martina Renner auch von den Linken auch schon mal auf der Bühne, eben bei NNP 256.
Ich wusste, dass ich was Falsches da hatte.
Genau.
Da war uns ja, sagen wir mal, dieser aktivistische Teil,
wir haben es ja auch bisher immer bei den Live-Sendungen so gehalten,
jetzt bei der letzten Sendung, was man,
da doch eigentlich auch ähnlich, aber im Prinzip, wir sind ja immer nach Gesprächspartnern
aus, die so in gewisser Hinsicht so dieses Aktivistische auch vertreten.
Deswegen hatten wir Anka eingeladen, deswegen haben wir auch Martina Renner eingeladen.
Und trotzdem.
Das kann man jetzt, können wir uns vorwerfen, aber ich glaube,
das ist einfach ein ganz normaler Effekt auch.
Man nimmt natürlich oft und in zunehmendem Maße oder vielleicht auch vorwiegend,
eine Präsenz im Bundestag über die Gesamtwirkung der Partei, die man vertritt, war.
Und das ist immer so ein bisschen so ein Auf und Ab. Du hast viele, auch viele gute Leute,
ich kann nicht mal nur netzpolitisch sagen, aber du hast natürlich auch netzpolitisch
wichtige Leute bei den Grünen.
So in Konstantin von Notz oder so hat da eine Rolle gespielt und auch bei der,
FDP gab es immer wieder Leute, die dort hervorgetreten sind.
Trotzdem geht dieses Einzelwerk natürlich dann im Gesamtgewitter der gesamtpolitischen
Arbeit der Partei unter und wird halt auch schnell in so ein Regal reingestoßen.
Und ich glaube, dass wir alle auch so eine Art,
innere Distanz zu dem Parteiwesen entwickelt haben,
dass wir so Parteien an sich, das ist auch, sagen wir mal, so ein Chaosumfeld
ja auch sehr verbreitet,
so in dem Moment, wo etwas eine Partei ist, wird es auf einmal auch irgendwie,
das hätte fast der Feind gesagt, das ist ein bisschen übertrieben,
aber auf jeden Fall ist das auf einmal so ein.
Entpersonalisierter Korpus, der nur noch sozusagen mit einer Gesamtagenda vor
einem steht und man tendiert dazu,
das immer sozusagen als Gruppe wahrzunehmen, also als Block und nicht so sehr
auf die individuelle Arbeit, die viele Bundestagsabgeordnete oder auch ihre Mitarbeiter leisten.
Ich denke, das ist so der Effekt, der da auch ein bisschen bei uns eingetreten ist.
Ja, da sind wir sicherlich nicht alleine. Also ich glaube, das ist dann auch
schon mal sehr verbreitet.
Wir hatten jetzt auch in derselben Sendung mit Martina Renner hatten wir Jan-Philipp
Albrecht auch noch auf der Bühne.
Um da der Politiker-Anwesenheitsamnesie gleich nochmal draufzulegen.
Ob sich das hier um einen links-grün-versifften Podcast handelt?
Manche sagen so, manche sagen so.
Ja, aber du hast also, ich glaube genau das, was du als Effekt benennst,
ist natürlich, also der wirkt da schon.
Genau, aber trotzdem war es uns auch wichtig, besondere Leistungen dann auch
in gewisser Hinsicht auch mal hervorzustellen.
Also,
gelingt uns vielleicht nicht unbedingt immer.
Ja, in dem Fall ist es uns nicht gelungen, denke ich. Und das wurde auch zu Recht bemängelt.
Moniert, genau.
Also Anke, ich hoffe, du nimmst unsere Entschuldigung an.
So, kommen wir zur AI. Endlich mal hier spannende Technik und so.
Okay.
Nicht immer nur Politik. Wir haben Feedback bekommen, weil wir haben uns ja
über DeepSeek unterhalten und was das alles so macht.
Und dann, ich werde ja, muss ja zugeben, ich bin jetzt ein bisschen grumpy in letzter Zeit.
Du bist grumpy?
Ja. ich bin grumpy.
Wegen Deep Seek?
Nö, nicht wegen Deep Seek, nee, wegen Deutschland.
Deutschland macht mich grumpy. Wirklich.
Also da habe ich ein echtes Problem mit gerade. Das merkt man,
glaube ich, auch auf allen Kanälen. Da bin ich gerade echt ein bisschen ...
Es läuft nicht so gut zwischen mir und Deutschland. Sagen wir es mal so.
Also wir hatten schon ein besseres Verhältnis.
Also wenn Goldene Zwanziger ist, dann muss Deutschland auch mitmachen.
Und wenn da keiner mitmacht, stell dir vor, es ist Goldene Zwanziger und niemand geht hin.
Da macht eh keiner mehr mit, habe ich das Gefühl. Ich glaube,
ich kann das Projekt Goldene Zwanziger jetzt auch abblasen.
Nach fünf Jahren hätte sich da ja mal langsam so einen Trend einstellen müssen,
aber irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, wird das nix.
Anyway, wir haben über AI und Forschung gesprochen,
und speziell auch darüber, wie ich das in dem Moment auch eingeschätzt habe,
so die Dynamik in China, die Dynamik in USA, die Dynamik in Europa.
Einige haben sich beklagt, schon bei der Freakshow hatten wir das Thema ähnlich,
da kam dann gleich so Stimme auf, so ja, aber es gibt ja hier dieses und jenes
Leuchtturmprojekt in Europa, ja klar.
Leuchtturmprojekt, hör mir auf mit Leuchtturmprojekt.
Naja, so klar, blindes Huhn und so und vor allem, ich habe ja nicht gesagt,
dass hier niemand daran arbeitet oder so, es ist nur einfach keinerlei Dynamik da drin.
Und das liegt an dem Leuchtturm. Der Leuchtturm als architektonische Metapher
ist für jedes Projekt, an dessen Gelingen jemandem gelegen ist.
Es sei denn, es ist der Bau eines Leuchtturms. Ungeeignet.
Okay, weiter, sorry.
Gut, wir haben auf jeden Fall Post aus China bekommen, beziehungsweise ein Kommentar.
Es schreibt, jemand aus China, frag mich nur, warum da jetzt keinen realen Namen dran steht.
Als jemand, der selbst in China an der Optimierung von großen neuronalen Netzen
und deren Infrastruktur forscht, kann ich bestätigen, dass High-End Grafikkarten von Nvidia...
Hintergrund, das war die Diskussion um DeepSeq, ob sie denn nun wirklich mit
schlechter Hardware gearbeitet haben oder doch irgendwie Zugang zu guter AI-Hardware haben.
Dass High-End-Grafikkarten von Nvidia hier tatsächlich Mangelware sind.
Hier spielt also Effizienzoptimierung eine viel größere Rolle als beispielsweise in den USA.
Dies spiegelt sich auch in den Publikationen wieder.
Ein Großteil der Forschung in diesem Bereich kommt tatsächlich aus China.
Es war also abzusehen, dass irgendwann jemand aus China wie DeepSeek die Kosten
von LLM-Training und Inferenz, also Inferenz meint das Benutzen eines Modells, drastisch senken wird.
Die Ergebnisse von DeepSeek wurden von mehreren Firmen, unter anderem auch von
meinen Kollegen bereits reproduziert.
Zudem bauten sie auch auf viele
etablierte Techniken auf, wie zum Beispiel Quantisierung oder KV-Caches.
Natürlich darf man und sollte auch skeptisch sein, was die Ergebnisse von Forschungsarbeiten
anbelangt, insbesondere bei besonders guten Ergebnissen.
Allerdings ist es vor allem im KI-Bereich sehr einfach, Ergebnisse zu reproduzieren,
da in der Regel der komplette Stack und oft auch der Code der Autoren eines Papers quelloffen ist.
Wer da noch Daten manipuliert, betreibt praktisch Karriere-Selbstmord.
Eure abschließende Bemerkung finde ich sehr richtig. Hier sind die Menschen
neuen Technologien viel offener gegenüber. In China wird nicht gemeckert, sondern gehypt.
Ich denke, davon können wir uns in Deutschland und dem Fediverse ein wenig abgucken,
etwas optimistischer sein und ein bisschen mehr auf die Möglichkeiten schauen.
Ich möchte noch hinzufügen, Regulierung ist natürlich richtig und wichtig.
Was Musk und seine Doge-Chaoten da machen, ist bestenfalls blauäugig und grünschnäblig.
LLMs sind keine Orakel-, Wissensbasen oder Finanzexperten, sondern Textgeneratoren.
Einem LLM sollte nicht die Entscheidung zufallen, welche Stelle gestrichen werden
kann. Dennoch vermisse ich den Optimismus in der Diskussion um generative KI in der Öffentlichkeit.
Statt auf die Möglichkeiten zu schauen, hat sich die Diskussion früh um den
Energieverbrauch und die Halluzination gedreht, was die meisten als innerente
Aspekte der Technologie begreifen.
Dass aber spätere Iterationen der Technik diese Nachteile ausbügeln könnten,
haben sie nicht auf dem Schirm.
Oder dass generative KI für bestimmte Anwendungsfälle nicht verwendet werden
sollte, heißt nicht, dass sie für keine Anwendungsfälle zu gebrauchen ist.
Warum muss denn alles Neue erstmal scheiße sein? Warum können wir nicht eine
etwas differenziertere Betrachtungsweise pflegen?
Also jetzt stellst du hier für deutsche Verhältnisse die Systemfrage.
Das war auch meine Antwort im Kommentar. Weil Deutschland.
Tja, finde ich einen schönen Einblick.
Und ja, also auch dazu kann ich nur, ich glaube, dazu haben wir jetzt schon alles gesagt, das ist,
meine Sorge wäre, ja, dass wir bei, oder meine aktuelle Sorge ist durchaus,
dass wir bei diesem KI-Kram ungefähr den gleichen Fehler machen wie bei den Elektroautos.
So, guck mal, da sagt ja auch manchmal was Falsches.
Wer will denn was sagen, was manchmal was Falsches sagt, nimmt er doch lieber
mich als Menschen, der nie was Falsches sagt.
Wir haben noch nie einen Fehler gemacht hier bei uns.
Wir erinnern uns auch immer korrekt.
Genau, unsere das ist schon super.
Oder?
Auch in vielen Nerd-Beispielen, ist ja auch so KI-Bashing sehr beliebt, üblicherweise halt von,
Menschen, die eine besondere Expertise in dem Fachbereich haben, der da von KI,
in die die KI sich gerade einarbeitet. Und dann wird gesagt,
guck mal, das kann ich aber viel besser, im Detail macht der noch Fehler.
Ja,
dann wäre jetzt so der Moment, sich zu überlegen, wie lange braucht denn der
Lehrling noch, bis der das besser kann mit seinen besseren Augen und seinen
größeren Muskeln und so.
Aber letzten Freitag hat er abends einen Fehler gemacht, da musste ich ihn korrigieren.
Ja, super. Danke, Meister, für deine Daseinsberechtigung.
Aber Ja, natürlich hat die Maschine automatisch ein Auto gebaut.
Den Sportwagen hier. Sieht auch wirklich schick aus, aber die Spaltmaße.
Ja gut, die Spaltmaße sind ja wirklich peinlich.
Aber die Spaltmaße sind ein super Beispiel dafür, dass sich die meisten Leute
für diese Spaltmaster nicht interessieren.
Denen ist das nämlich scheißegal. Und das wäre auch meine Sorge bei den ganzen KI-Sachen.
Von mir aus stimmen da die Spaltmaster in den Texten nicht.
Aber du musst ja nicht andere Expertinnen überzeugen von deinem Ergebnis,
sondern eben einfache Leute, die ein Auto kaufen wollen oder einen Text lesen oder was auch immer.
Sich beim Programmieren helfen lassen wollen. Ja, genau.
Ein Programm nutzen, in dem es scheißegal ist, wie elegant dein Code ist,
weil irgendein KI-generierter Prozessor, der sowieso in Millisekunden ausführt,
Ob das jetzt elegant geschrieben ist oder nicht.
Und diese, ja, diese, also das, worauf Deutsche gerne mit Angst reagieren,
einfach umzuwandeln in, boah, geil, neu, cool, wird bestimmt besser,
wäre, könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass das ein Faktor ist, der diesem Land noch helfen könnte.
Ja, das wird schwierig. Zeckerkörper. Das merkt man auch gerade.
Ich bin ja gerade im Ausland und hier sind alle so nett. Was?
Ja, die führen was im Schilde drin.
Meinst du?
Nur dein Geld. Kann ja nicht sein. Grundlos nett.
Verdächtig. Gut, schauen wir mal in die deutsche Innenpolitik.
Da muss ich zugeben, da bin ich gerade ein bisschen weit von entfernt,
aber ich habe gehört, zwei langweilige ältere Herren haben sich langweilig geäußert im Fernsehen.
Und du schaust dir das auch noch an.
Ja.
Eher durch, also ich hab den Fehler gemacht und hab mir das Kanzlerduell angeschaut.
Wow. Wie lang war das?
Anderthalb Stunden.
Und,
ich muss sagen, dass ich danach also schlechter ging's mir lange nicht.
Emotional. und,
ich habe auch ein bisschen überlegt, woran das denn so lag, weil das war ja
völlig klar, dass das wenig gute Laune machen würde,
und ich denke, es lag daran, einerseits über welche Themen in welcher Menge gesprochen wurde,
Und auch wie.
Bei der Zeit kann man sich anschauen, wie die Redezeiten waren.
Das ist eigentlich die interessanteste Frage hier.
Von den 90 Minuten empfiehlen, ich runde jetzt immer auf, es empfiehlen 13 Minuten
auf Asylpolitik und 8 Minuten auf Brandmauer.
Damit ist ja dann schon mal ein sehr entscheidender Teil ein großer Teil dieser Sendung bestimmt.
Was dazu gesagt wurde ist dann natürlich noch umso dramatischer weil Olaf Scholz sagte,
es gab nie schärfere Einwanderungsgesetze in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
als meine Ja stimmt, weil die auch so gut wie nie einfacher werden.
Es wird ja nie irgendwie wirklich was gelockert.
Alle derartigen, alle Bereiche wie Einwanderung, Sicherheit und so weiter werden
ja immer nur restriktiver.
Insofern ist das ungefähr so wie als wenn Tim Cook sagen würde,
es gab nie ein besseres iPhone als das, was wir jetzt auf den Markt gebracht haben.
Ja klar, es wäre ja auch wirklich überraschend, wenn ich sagen würde,
etwas weniger Power in das neue iPhone gemacht.
Und in dieser gesamten Diskussion,
Haben die nicht ein einziges Mal überlegt, ob die Schwierigkeiten der Migrationspolitik
an irgendetwas anderem liegen könnten, als es sind zu viele Leute.
Es wurde nicht gesagt, vielleicht könnten wir besser mit denen umgehen.
Es wurde nicht gesagt, vielleicht brauchen wir die sogar. oder vielleicht brauchen
wir Leute, also in keiner Form.
Das war schockierend, weil hier in einem Land, in dem die Leute wegsterben,
das Land wird ja immer kleiner.
Die Bevölkerung wächst nicht in der Menge nach, irgendjemand muss hier dann
auch nochmal die Rente für diese ganzen alten Säcke zahlen oder verdienen.
Und das ist, also all diese Probleme, das war in keiner Form mehr eine Auseinandersetzung,
in der zwischen diesen beiden Kandidaten überhaupt noch eine unterschiedliche Meinung herrschte.
Die haben eigentlich da beide gestanden und sich nur darin überboten wer irgendwie
geiler abschiebt und also Gedanken wie wir brauchen Zuwanderung in diesem Land oder Gedanken wie.
Vielleicht liegt das auch daran, dass und das ist jetzt nur eine Erläuterung,
dass wir aus dem Umfeld der zugewanderten Menschen diese Gewalttaten sehen dass
die eben bei uns die schlechteste Versorgung von allen haben und wir das da
nicht merken, wie bei anderen Menschen,
wenn die durchdrehen und geisteskrank sind oder sonstige Probleme haben.
Eine derartige Frage, die war unerhört.
Und dann ist es dem an einer Stelle,
ich glaube das war der Bereich, das ist hier in der Zeit mit Identitätspolitik
zum Glück nur eine Minute, aber auch diese Minute war zu viel,
wo dann die Leute gefragt wurden,
ja finden sie das jetzt in Ordnung
in Deutschland, dass wir mehr als ein Geschlecht anerkennen oder nicht?
Mehr als zwei Geschlechter, Entschuldigung, das zweite Geschlecht hat ja jetzt
lange genug darum gekämpft, anerkannt zu werden und jetzt erstmal die Existenz von,
weiteren Geschlechtern anerkennt und dann kommt irgendwie Merz und sagt,
nee, finde ich falsch, alles männlich, fertig und.
Scholz erzählt irgendwie so eine dümmste Geschichte aus seinem Leben,
wie eine Frau zu ihm gekommen ist bei irgendeiner Wahlkampfveranstaltung und
die Frau hat von sich gesagt, ich bin Maurer und deswegen will Olaf Scholz jetzt
dass jeder das so sagen kann,
wie er möchte und hat da irgendwie also auch so eine dümmste, also,
so schlecht zu dem Thema gesprochen, dass es wirklich belastend war.
Okay, also 13 und acht Minuten Asylpolitik und Brandmauer,
sieben Minuten Wirtschaftspolitik, wo man sich denkt, naja, okay,
vielleicht wäre das ein Bereich gewesen, in dem man sich ein bisschen mehr darüber
auseinandersetzen könnte.
Da sind aber dann auch nur irgendwie so Plattitüden gefallen.
Da wurde nicht inhaltlich darüber diskutiert, wie man die Wirtschaft dieses
Landes irgendwie in eine bessere Richtung schieben könnte.
Da wurde dann nur so, ja, hier ist eine Insolvenzwelle, ging dem Land nie schlechter
als unter ihnen, die Wirtschaft kotzt über den Wirtschaftsminister ab oder so.
Er wurde nicht inhaltlich drüber gesprochen.
Dann ging es um Verteidigungsausgaben und Steuerpolitik, jeweils so fünf Minütchen.
Fünf Minuten um die Schuldenbremse. Auch da keine, also es fehlte so an einer,
warum machen wir das überhaupt?
Da werden dann wirklich so diese Sprüche wiederholt.
Irgendwie so, das kann man nicht auf den, Schulden muss man irgendwann auch bezahlen. Ja.
Also irgendwie so Kleinsparer-Mentalitätssprüche, die leider nicht der Komplexität
der Situation gerecht werden.
Zum Beispiel, dass bei einer rasenden Inflation Schulden gar nicht so schlecht sind.
Weil das wird ja billiger, die zurückzuzahlen. Das wird ja einfach nur billiger.
Und es ist total klug, Schulden zu machen.
Habe ich übrigens deutsche Kleinsparmentalität in meinem Leben viel zu spät
verstanden, dass es sehr klug gewesen wäre, wenn ich mir mit,
weiß ich nicht, mit Anfang 20 in Berlin eine Wohnung gekauft hätte.
200.000 Euro, eine Summe, unvorstellbar, wo soll man dieses ganze Geld herkriegen?
Überlegst du, wenn ich das gemacht hätte? Aber okay, lass mal.
Solche Gedanken, also darüber nachzudenken, dass man hier gerade mit einem Sachverhalt
zu tun hat, nämlich der Positionierung der Bundesrepublik Deutschland in einer sich ändernden Welt,
sind einfach nur mit blöden Sprüchen daher.
Wurde über die Ukraine und die Außenpolitik von Donald Trump gesprochen,
auch da habe ich irgendwie nichts Sinnvolles gehört und am Ende haben sie sogar
noch wieder über Energieversorgung gesprochen,
wo dann wieder über Windräder so ein Scheiß geflucht wurde und das war auf einem Niveau,
dass ich wirklich.
Also schwere eine richtig tiefe Beklommenheit empfunden habe,
dass die Diskussion in diesem Land in ihrer Tiefe,
vollständig verloren ist und auch in der Gewichtung der Probleme dieses Landes,
einige Dinge wirklich enorm schief gehen.
Und das hat mich wirklich längere Zeit, wirklich ein, zwei Tage,
war ich wirklich so und habe gedacht, okay, hat wird nichts mehr mit den goldenen Zwanzigern.
Wenn wir dieses Potenzial, wenn wir dieses Personal und dieses Potenzial bei
den Leuten haben und in den Diskussionen, Katastrophe.
Ich meine, das heißt Kanzler-Duell, nicht Kanzler.
Die Zukunft Deutschlands oder sowas. Es geht ja sozusagen um den Duell-Aspekt,
wer kommt da besser rüber, wer macht die geileren Sprüche, es ist halt alles
so eine Show und wird ja danach auch bewertet mit wer hat jetzt gewonnen und so.
Das hat mir übrigens ganz kurz, das hat mir auch den Rest gegeben,
dass nach dem Kanzler-Duell, da habe ich noch einen Fehler gemacht, mich auszuschalten.
Zweiter Fehler.
Was kam dann? Dschungelcamp oder was?
Ne, so ähnlich. Hier Markus Söder. Und ich glaube, das war dann Lars Klingbeil,
die dann da, aber so Dschungelcamp-mäßig oder Deutschland sucht den Superkanzler-mäßig
dann da irgendwie den Auftritt ihrer Zöglinge da beurteilt haben.
Und Söder natürlich irgendwie keine Sekunde, er konnte keinen Satz sagen,
ohne sich über die Grünen aufzuregen.
Also du denkst dann irgendwie nur so, boah, ey, also wirklich,
es war wirklich sehr belastend, weil du diese,
kindische Auseinandersetzung auf einem auf Stammtischniveau über wirklich sensible
Probleme dieses Landes, das hat mich wirklich wirklich nachhaltig belastet.
Wie war die Moderation?
Die haben irgendwie darauf geachtet, dass beide gleich viel Redezeit haben.
Ja, aber ich meine, so wie du fragst, kriegst du ja auch Ergebnisse.
Das meine ich ja eben.
Sicherlich hätten diese beiden Leute, die da waren, auch 90 Minuten platt über
Asylpolitik und Brandmauer weitergeredet.
Das hättest du aber mit jedem anderen Thema auch machen können.
Wenn du denen gesagt hättest, erstes Thema, Pflege. Lass uns mal überlegen,
wie wir das Ding hier angehen.
Und dann hätten wir auch 90 Minuten darüber reden können.
Und das ist auch das, was mich natürlich an diesem Kanzlerduell so ärgert,
dass dann da irgendwie über Asylpolitik und Brandmauer so lange geredet wird.
Und natürlich geprägt auch dadurch, dass da wenige Tage vorher dieser Anschlag war.
Jetzt muss man aufpassen, es gab ja jetzt gerade wieder einen in München.
Wo ich übrigens an dem Tag war. Und ich war auch nicht weit weg von da,
wo der Anschlag passiert ist.
Und ich war ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen zunächst emotional empört,
dass ich aus meinem engsten Freundes- und Familienkreis, die wussten alle,
dass ich da bin, keiner hat irgendwie so, ey Linus, wie geht's dir? gefragt.
Mich nachher so ein bisschen scherzhaft darüber echauffiert,
aber ich fand das ehrlich gesagt ein schönes Symbol, der Ausgeglichenheit,
dass sie sich gesagt haben, naja,
wenn er auf der Verdi-Demo gewesen wäre, dann hätten wir es wahrscheinlich jetzt mitbekommen.
Mir hast du nicht gesagt, wo du bist.
Du hättest mich auch nicht gefragt.
Geht auch keinem was an. Aber,
ich fand das ...
Und dann haben sie ja häufig verwendete Wörter bei der Zeit.
Sehr schön. Also bei beiden Großdeutschland, klar, sie reden ja auch über Deutschland,
könnte man auch wegnehmen.
Bei Olaf Scholz dann danach, Milliarden, Herr Merz, Europa, verdienen Regierung,
Leute, der hat immer ganz normale Leute gesagt, das stimmt, ja und betrifft,
ganz viel betrifft und Bundestag.
Ja, und Friedrich Merz hat gesagt, Herr Bundeskanzler und Herr Scholz,
Frage, ja, AfD, Grüne, Milliarden und Problem.
Ja, das sind ja ein paar andere. Jetzt könnte, hätte man das da natürlich noch
ein bisschen berichtigen können, dass man irgendwie Herr Bundeskanzler und Herr
Merz rausnimmt oder so, das hätte man besser machen können.
Aber naja.
Ich habe also nichts verpasst. Das ist so in etwa auch alles,
liegt so vollkommen im Erwartungsbereich, ehrlich gesagt.
Also ich finde solche Veranstaltungen ja nicht so interessant.
Nein, wie gesagt, ich sage ja auch, es war ein Fehler.
Naja, gut, ich meine, du hast es ja, für den Podcast hast du dich ja geopfert.
Ja, genau. Seht ihr mal, was muss ich mir. Dann gibt es nachher einen Faktencheck
und da geht es dann auch einfach nur um die ganzen Aussagen zur Migration, ja.
So, wie viele, also das ist wirklich irre, ne?
Wie viele Abschiebungen und Zurückweisungen gab es? Das ist jetzt dann im Faktencheck.
Wie viel haben wir denn jetzt hier zurückgewiesen und abgeschoben?
Müssen wir jetzt mal gucken, ne? Wer hat denn da äh, äh, und, und,
das war alles so off, off track, ja.
Ja, vor allem, was sollen, ich meine, warum denn ausgerechnet die beiden Fatzkes,
Meine SPD steht bei was? 14% oder so?
Naja, ich finde es ist schon in Ordnung, den amtierenden Kanzler und den nächsten
Kanzler einmal zum Schlagaustausch zu bitten.
Das kann man schon verstehen.
Und ich glaube, es gab ja dann auch irgendwie Kanzlerquartett oder Quadruel
oder wie das dann heißt kürzlich.
Das haben wir auch nicht mehr angeguckt. Das gab es jetzt gerade, Tim.
Das Problem bei sowas ist, da rennt dann Alice Weidel rum.
Das ist ja jetzt, dann kannst du dir auch vorstellen, dass es den anderen jetzt nicht gelingt.
Ich bin schon ruhig.
Dieses schwarze Niveau-Loch da irgendwie.
Ich hab nichts gesagt. Okay, gut.
Aber ist da jetzt noch irgendwie viel für uns zu kommentieren dabei?
Nee. Also du hast dich sozusagen geopfert für uns beide. Ich find das toll.
Und jetzt freu ich mich über die Zusammenfassung Und ich fühle mich bestätigt
in der Annahme, dass eigentlich nichts passiert ist, was mich jetzt groß interessieren müsste.
Dann lass uns doch mal zum nächsten Thema übergehen.
Ja, ähnlich.
In den letzten Tagen fand die Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz statt.
Eine Veranstaltung, die glaube ich auch schon seit Jahrzehnten in München stattfindet.
Und so ein bisschen einen neutralen Boden für politische Auseinandersetzungen bieten soll,
idealerweise natürlich für Frieden sorgt, weil da Menschen sich austauschen oder sowas.
Seit 62 Jahren gibt es die Veranstaltung.
Und vielleicht zur Situation,
Es gibt Analysen, die davon ausgehen, dass Putin ab irgendwo zwischen 2026 und
2029 einen Konflikt mit der NATO suchen könnte.
Das sagen nun wirklich sehr viele. Tim wird da gleich auch noch was zu sagen.
Aber das ist die aktuelle Situation.
Wir haben einen weitergehenden Krieg in der Ukraine, Angriff von Russland,
muss ich auch keinem erklären,
Donald Trump hat jetzt in einem auch, ich glaube in,
sowas Asoziales habe ich lange nicht gehört irgendwie kürzlich bekannt gegeben,
dass er da gerne den Gaza-Streifen hätte, um da sowas wie die Riviera hochzuziehen eine Hotelregion,
Frankreich und Italien,
und erwartet war eigentlich dass achso und dann hatte Trump auch noch angefangen
mit Putin darüber zu reden, wie man jetzt hier den Krieg in der Ukraine beendet.
In dieser und in dieser Situation wurde eigentlich erwartet Nun ja, jetzt wird der J.D.
Vance, der Vizepräsident, bei dieser Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz potenziell bekannt geben,
wie sich die USA die Zeit nach dem Ukraine-Krieg vorstellen und welche Rolle
Europa dabei zu spielen hat.
Es wurde erwartet, dass er einen größeren Abzug der US-Truppen aus Europa verkünden
würde und dann quasi den Leuten, die da sind, erklären würde,
so, seht mal zu, wie er den Scheiß jetzt hier geklärt kriegt.
Wir haben Frieden geschlossen und dieser Frieden muss ja dann irgendwie gesichert
werden. Wurde erwartet, dass er das eben Europa überlässt.
Und stattdessen ist er da hingegangen und hat eine Rede über Zensur und Meinungsfreiheit gehalten,
in der er sich, also das Besorgnis darüber äußerte,
dass es in Europa jetzt irgendwie keine Meinungsfreiheit mehr gäbe. hat da ein paar.
Beispiele benannt, wo ich jetzt erstmal sagen muss, die natürlich sehr gut geeignet
waren, dieses Argument zu bringen.
Klar, wäre jetzt auch dumm gewesen, keine guten Beispiele zu nehmen.
Und er hat sich dann am Ende noch dazu geäußert, dass jetzt irgendwie,
was ja durchaus getan wurde, dass die Deutschen sich jetzt auch noch darüber
aufregen, dass Elon Musk sich in den Wahlkampf einmischt.
Und da hat er so sinngemäß gesagt, wenn wir seit zehn Jahren Greta Thunberg
ertragen müssen, dann könnt ihr ja wohl mal ein paar Monate Elon Musk ertragen.
Und also das war auch hier wieder, es gibt einen Unterschied zwischen Elon Musk,
dem reichsten Menschen der Erde,
der sich mal eben Twitter gekauft und nach seinem Gusto umgebaut hat.
Und dann eben auch noch quasi jetzt, nachdem er,
quasi auch noch in der Regierung irgendwie rumputscht oder Kuhs,
die putschen ja nichts, leider nicht, das macht er als nächstes dann noch irgendwann,
ja, dann hat er wieder irgendwie eine Leinketa gezogen und putscht gegen Trump oder so, ja,
also da gibt es einfach einen strukturellen Unterschied zwischen Greta Thunberg und Elon Musk.
Ja, Greta Thunberg kämpft mit den Mitteln einer Teenagerin um Aufmerksamkeit.
Elon Musk kontrolliert Aufmerksamkeit.
Und also auch da, und das vor allem vor dem Hintergrund, dass die gerade die Weltordnung.
Nicht umsortieren, sondern in meiner Wahrnehmung schon auch ihren Einfluss darauf,
wirklich aufs Spiel setzen.
Also ich kann mir diese USA als verlässlicher Partner, ich hatte das in der
letzten Sendung ja schon angesprochen,
Also ich also mir fällt nichts besseres ein, also,
Russland und China können sich doch nichts schöneres vorstellen,
als dass jetzt die USA ihren Einfluss auf der Welt auch noch selbst demontieren.
Ja, okay. Da war jetzt einiges drin.
Also zunächst einmal, was J.D.
Vance da gemacht hat, ist halt irgendwie offensichtlich erstmal geht es erstmal
darum, die nächst anstehenden Wahlen in Europa zu beeinflussen.
Das ist halt einfach klassisches rechtes Propaganda-Vorgehen, irgendwelche
Einzelfälle aufgreifen und daraus irgendwie eine Bedrohung der Demokratie herbeireden
zu wollen, ausgerechnet in Europa,
ausgerechnet von dieser Regierung, ich lache.
Ja, also da geht es halt sozusagen nur darum, diese Gelegenheit gerade zu nutzen,
um in irgendeiner Form so eine Agenda zu setzen.
Das war sagen wir mal jetzt das, was ich aus seiner Rede primär entnommen habe.
Also das ist absolut richtig. Ich denke, ich muss nur kurz dazu noch betonen,
als ich gerade sagte, es wurde eine andere Rede erwartet,
das was, wovon man eigentlich ausgeht, ist, dass der ursprünglich eine andere
Rede dabei hatte und aus irgendwelchen Gründen zurückgepfiffen wurde, die zu halten.
Das ist so die Interpretation gerade dessen, was da passiert ist.
Aus welchem Grund auch immer.
Aber das war so die Interpretation vieler, zumal halt der Chef der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz, das ist nicht mehr der Ischinger, sondern ich habe den
Namen gerade vergessen, war auch mal im Kanzleramt,
der kurz vorher gesagt hat, dass man eine Rede mit bestimmten Inhalten erwartet
und es wäre jetzt wahrscheinlich auch, sag ich mal, grundsätzlich davon auszugehen,
dass der eventuell wusste, was da ursprünglich mal geplant wurde.
Also die Einschätzung ist, dass der diese Rede kurzfristig geändert hat oder
kurzfristig eine andere halten musste.
Das kann ich sagen.
Das nochmal als Kontext. Ändert natürlich nichts daran, was du gerade gesagt hast.
Chef ist Jens Stoltenberg, der ehemalige NATO-Generalsekretär.
Oh, der jetzt durch Rütte ersetzt wurde.
Ja, das kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen,
weil ich glaube in dieser ganzen Trump-Regierung kann man es nennen,
also was sich da sozusagen, dieser Mafia-Clan, der sich da jetzt gerade breit macht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die auch irgendwie nennenswert nur in irgendeiner Form
irgendeinen außenpolitischen Kompass am Start haben.
Also die wissen derzeit nicht so richtig, wohin sie wollen, weil am Ende interessiert
Außenpolitik halt, Donald Trump halt einen Scheiß.
Das ist für ihn halt auch nur irgendeine Methode, um irgendwo Geld und Macht
und Einfluss und Anerkennung, also das, was er so als Anerkennung empfindet, einzusammeln.
Deswegen trifft er sich jetzt halt auch mit Putin. Da wird halt nichts bei rauskommen
und dieses ganze Gerede von Friedensvertrag mit Putin aushandeln.
Und die Europäer sind nicht dabei und die Ukrainer auch nicht.
Da kann ich ja einfach nur drüber lachen. Ja, das ist halt einfach absurd.
Die Einschätzung, die du noch geäußert hast bezüglich der Absichten Russlands,
teile ich insofern, als dass es selbstverständlich so ist, dass Russland ein imperiales Ziel hat.
Denen geht es halt einfach mindestens um die Wiederherstellung der Sowjetunion.
Alles drunter ist uninteressant und derzeit hat Putin auch an Frieden überhaupt
gar kein Interesse, weil er derzeit mit Frieden sein Land überhaupt nicht mehr
unter Kontrolle bekommen würde.
Also Frieden ist eigentlich das Schlimmste, was derzeit Putin passieren kann,
weil dann bricht die Wirtschaft, so wie sie jetzt derzeit aufgestellt ist, komplett zusammen.
Das ist auch alles nur so auf Zeit.
Die Einschätzung, wann jetzt wie wo da ein Angriff kommen könnte,
gut, das ist derzeit nur theoretisch, weil solange die in der Ukraine so kämpfen,
wie sie es derzeit tun mit den ganzen Ressourcenproblemen, die sie jetzt in
zunehmendem Maße aufbauen,
sind sie halt mitnichten auch nur im Ansatz, in der Lage.
Sowas wie Finnland groß in Probleme zu bringen.
Im Baltikum sieht es durch die kurzen Wege schon ein bisschen anders aus.
Und die Feststellung, Russland könnte demnächst vielleicht mit der NATO einen Konflikt suchen,
da muss ich sagen, habt ihr schon mal in den letzten drei Jahren Nachrichten gehört?
Was passiert denn da täglich?
Also wir hatten jetzt glaube ich allein in den letzten vier Wochen drei oder
vier durchschnittene Kabel in der Ostsee, Kommunikations- und Stromkabel zwischen Schweden,
Finnland, Estland, Litauen.
Permanent gibt es Attacken auf Infrastruktur,
permanent gibt es vor allem auch Attacken auf unsere Informationssphäre und
Russland ist längst im Krieg mit uns.
Das ist sozusagen etwas, was
ich überhaupt nicht verstehe, dass das überhaupt keiner wahrhaben will.
Und das setzt sich halt erst langsam durch.
Ja, also gut, dass du das nochmal sagst. Ich weiß nicht, Konflikt suchen,
also ich meine, was die damit meinen, ist angreifen.
Also mit Waffen im Zweifelsfall,
keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht, aber Polen rüstet gerade, glaube ich,
ziemlich massiv auf, weil die gemerkt haben, dass sie irgendwie im Weg sind.
Keiner rüstet so massiv aus wie Polen, ja.
Das scheinen die einzigen zu sein, die es irgendwie schon gecheckt haben.
Nö, das Baltikum hat es auch gecheckt und Finnland hat es auch gecheckt und
Schweden hat es gecheckt.
Ja, aber bei diesem Kanzlerduell hatte ich irgendwie nicht den Eindruck,
dass da irgendeiner irgendwas gecheckt hat.
Nee, sorry, Deutschland gehört auf diese Liste auch nicht drauf.
Also das ist definitiv derzeit eher ein ost- und nordeuropäisches Thema.
Und,
Ja, okay, gut.
Ich weiß, es ist ein schweres Thema und muss es auch einfach mal klar aussprechen.
Es gibt nicht irgendwie eine mögliche theoretische Bedrohung in der Zukunft,
sondern die Bedrohung ist halt jetzt da. Wir haben ja erlebt,
was passiert ist. Ukraine-Krieg hat begonnen.
Putin hat sich verzockt. Erstmal hat er halt die Situation, die militärische
Situation der Ukraine vollkommen falsch eingeschätzt, vor allem auch seine eigene.
Kam nicht voran. Statt in drei Tagen Kiew einzunehmen, sind sie jetzt seit drei
Jahren am Kämpfen mit einem Ressourcenaufwand, der nur vom Zweiten Weltkrieg noch getoppt wird.
Und die Reaktion Europas hat er dann gleich so ernst genommen,
dass er dann uns erstmal das Gas abgedreht hat.
Ich meine, wenn man das jetzt nicht als Kriegsreaktion versteht,
dann weiß ich nicht, dann denkt man wahrscheinlich ein bisschen anders über die Welt nach.
Und das ist halt einfach die Situation. Auf der anderen Seite leben wir in dieser Problematik,
dass wir die Fähigkeiten, die Russland real hat, eigentlich überschätzen.
Russland wird viel zu sehr als eine größere Gefahr, das stimmt nicht ganz,
das ist nicht die Formulierung, die ich suche.
Russland wird stärker eingeschätzt, als es ist.
Man hat hier vor allem Angst vor Russland. Und deswegen sind viele halt auch
nicht bereit, diesem Drängen, das Russland hat, die Stirn zu bieten.
Dabei ist genau diese Schwäche, die Europa zeigt, das, was Putin anfeuert,
hier immer weiterzumachen, weil er halt einfach immer wieder sieht,
dass hier alle einknicken und sich kaufen lassen und so weiter.
Und das ist so dieser Gesinnungswandel, der halt erstmal stattfinden muss,
bis sich Europa dort verbindet.
Aufstellen lassen kann. Bezug auf die USA und den Mangel an Unterstützung zeigt
sich halt jetzt immer deutlicher, wenn wir nicht für unsere eigene Sicherheit
sorgen können, dann haben wir ein Problem.
Und deswegen muss es einfach auf eine europäische Einigung hinauslaufen,
wie wir sie so bisher noch nicht hatten.
Guter Punkt. Das Einzige, was ich nicht ganz verstehe, ist, aber das werden
wir, glaube ich, auch nicht mehr unbedingt auf eine Linie bringen, wenn ich da lese,
die sind in der Lage, also es geht ja bei diesen Berichten oder bei diesen Prognosen,
dass ein Angriff auf die NATO stattfindet, auch darum, dass sie dazu in der Lage sein werden.
Also wenn die sagen, hier, die planen einen Angriff, dann heißt das ja auch,
dass sie den durchführen können.
Also wenn die könnten, hätten sie es ja vielleicht längst gemacht.
Und wenn die jetzt sagen, also wenn hier die Zeit, wenn hier ein Zeithorizont genannt ist,
dann hat dieser Zeithorizont ja auch damit zu tun, dass eben Waffen aktuell
produziert werden und eine Vorbereitung der oder die notwendigen Vorbereitungen
eines Angriffs erfolgen.
Ja, naja gut, ich meine, Russland hat derzeit extreme Probleme,
überhaupt genug zu produzieren, um das auszugleichen, was sie in der Ukraine derzeit verballern.
Das gilt zumindest so für Fahrzeuge und so, also sie haben einfach ein akutes Fahrzeugproblem.
Also greifen wir uns da mit Raketen an?
Genau, Raketen, das können sie irgendwie relativ gut so, da haben sie halt auch
so einiges, aber im Prinzip hat Europa auch alles, zumindest im Verbund mit
den USA hat Europa alles, um dem auch etwas entgegenzusetzen.
Das Vernichtungspotenzial der NATO übersteigt das Vernichtungspotenzial Russlands deutlich.
Wenn man die USA mit einrechnet. Die Frage ist halt nur, was passiert,
wenn die USA in irgendeiner Form wirklich in so einen Modus verfallen,
wo sie denken so, ach, Europa, who cares.
Was halt durchaus sein kann. Auch wenn das, glaube ich, im Wesentlichen derzeit
einfach alles noch ein bisschen Getue ist.
Nur wir beobachten ja auch eine.
Unfassbare Selbstzerstörung derzeit der USA. Also das, was dort derzeit dieser
Trump-Regierung quasi erlaubt wird, weil niemand in der Lage zu sein scheint,
dem in irgendeiner Form etwas entgegenzusetzen, ist ja die vollständige Demontage
auch der außenpolitischen Kraft der USA.
Weil wenn es halt so weiter geht, dass sie jetzt irgendwie sagen,
so ja, ach Verbündete, who cares, die sind ja irgendwie alle zu vogue,
dann verliert natürlich die USA eine Menge an Allianzen weltweit und dann kann
man das halt auch mit dem Pazifik und mit Taiwan dann halt auch irgendwie vergessen
und dann haben wir halt so ein richtiges Problem und zwar überall.
Und das ist definitiv ein großes Problem.
Dabei schaden sich die USA natürlich vor allem selbst und uns eben quasi dann
nachrangig automatisch auch mit.
Da muss man mal gucken, wie das so mit den Reinigungs- und Widerstandskräften
in der amerikanischen Gesellschaft wirklich aussieht.
Ich kann das nicht einschätzen, aber es ist definitiv erforderlich,
dass dem etwas entgegengesetzt wird.
Ich meine, die USA steuern jetzt im Prinzip mit 180 Stundenkilometern auf eine
akute Verfassungskrise zu, weil worauf es halt derzeit hinausläuft, ist, dass...
Elon Musk und Peter Thiel und diese ganzen anderen Bitcoin-libertären Schwachmaten,
die halt irgendwie lieber alles brennen sehen, als dass sie in irgendeiner Form zurückweichen,
werden dafür sorgen, dass der Staatsapparat komplett demontiert wird.
Also allein schon so, ich meine, wir diskutieren jetzt darüber,
das Bildungsministerium abzuschaffen und USAID haben sie schon irgendwie abgeschafft,
das ist alles vollkommen absurd.
Sie machen Purges im FBI, im CIA, sie haben jetzt irgendwie alle Kontaktpersonen,
die aus China berichten, irgendwie in E-Mails geleakt und so weiter.
Also da wird demnächst eine mittlere Katastrophe stattfinden im Intelligence-Bereich.
Keiner vertraut den USA mehr, niemand wird mit den USA Information-Sharing betreiben,
um nicht die eigenen Agenten zu gefährden. Also es läuft jetzt auf so ein richtiges Chaos hinaus.
Und am Ende kann halt eigentlich nur, weil jetzt Elon Musk zehnmal am Tag postet,
wie schlimm doch Gerichte sind, wird also im Prinzip die Judikative jetzt auch
noch komplett hops genommen.
Und am Ende wird es halt auf eine Entscheidung des Verfassungsgerichts der USA
hinauslaufen, wo ich halt sagen würde, da stehen die Chancen relativ gut,
dass obwohl die alle von Trump bestellt wurden.
Trotzdem gegen ihn entschieden wird.
Und wenn sie das dann ignorieren, wenn sie sich sozusagen der Judikative nicht
beugen, dann wird es richtig unangenehm. Ja, klar.
Da frage ich mich, wer dann noch übrig ist, um die dazu zu bringen,
sich der Judikative zu beugen.
Wir wissen ja, wie die mit Institutionen aus umgehen, die ihnen,
zum Beispiel sowas wie eine Wahl, die sie verlieren.
Und meine große Sorge wäre, dass so eine Judikative einfach kein Social Network
hat auf der sie erklären können, worum es geht Ja.
Ja klar also das ist halt genau der Punkt und wenn sie dann halt das trotzdem
machen dann ist Chaos und im Zweifelsfall halt auch irgendwie Bürgerkrieg oder
irgendwie sowas also das,
also das sieht nicht gut aus um das
mal mit meinem gewohnten Optimismus auszudrücken ist ein bisschen shaky.
Was da abgeht ist ein bisschen besorgniserregend ja meinst du, sieht gar nicht.
Gar nicht so rosig alles alles nicht so rosig wir haben das immer so.
Dann kommen wir zu dem zum KI-Gipfel, nachdem wir jetzt schon einige Zeit über
Themen gesprochen haben.
Wo wir jetzt wieder gefreut werden. Ja, okay.
Es gab einen KI-Gipfel in Paris,
und da wurde ein Abschlusskommuniqué unterzeichnet und das sagte,
es geht also, sie wollen sechs Prioritäten haben mit dieser neuen Technologie.
Erstens, Zugänglichkeit will man fördern, um die digitale Kluft zu verringern.
Zweitens, man will sicherstellen, dass KI offen, inklusiv, transparent,
ethisch sicher und vertrauenswürdig ist unter Berücksichtigung internationaler
Rahmenbedingungen für alle.
Dann möchte man Innovationen im Bereich KI gedeihen lassen, indem Bedingungen
für ihre Entwicklung geschaffen und Machtkonzentration vermieden wird.
Wenn man sagt, also entweder du schaffst Bedingungen für ihre Entwicklung oder
du vermeidest Marktkonzentration, nicht Machtkonzentration. Entschuldigung.
Aber es ist das Gleiche, denn Marktkonzentration.
Scheint ja das zu sein,
was oder die Aussicht auf Marktkonzentration
ist auf das, was Innovation gedeihen lässt, weil man sagt,
okay, alles klar, wenn wir das hinkriegen, dann konzentriert sich der Markt
bei uns und dann können wir unseren Einsatz hier wieder remonetarisieren.
Sie möchten den Einsatz von KI fördern, der die Zukunft der Arbeit und der Arbeitsmärkte
positiv gestaltet und Chancen für nachhaltiges Wachstum bietet.
Auch das ist natürlich interessant, weil entweder die KI ist innovativ,
dann wird sie halt Arbeitsplätze kosten.
Oder du sagst, wir brauchen hier nachhaltiges Wachstum und der soll die Zukunft
der Arbeit positiv gestalten.
Dafür musst du halt die Zukunft der Arbeit auch anders verstehen.
Außerdem soll KI für Menschen und Planeten nachhaltig sein und die internationale
Zusammenarbeit zur Förderung der Koordination,
in der internationalen Regierungsführung soll gestärkt werden.
Also wir wollen gemeinsam diese Technologie in Grenzen halten und uns da koordinieren,
um das nachhaltig zu machen.
So klingt für mich ein bisschen nach so ein paar Sprüchen.
Also wenig konkret.
Was man so sagt auf so einem Gipfel, ja.
Was man so sagt auf so einem Gipfel.
Spannend ist, USA und Großbritannien haben die Unterschrift verweigert und haben
das folgendermaßen begründet.
Erstens, übermäßige Regulierung.
JD Vance wieder, der übrigens ein herausragend guter Redner ist.
Diese gesamte Rede da vor der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz hat der ohne Blatt gehalten.
Die hat der aus dem Kopf gehalten. Wirklich gut.
Also ich wusste nicht, warum man irgendwie so einen komischen,
halbgehangenen Typen da als seinen Vizepräsidenten nimmt,
aber weil der im Gegensatz zu Donald Trump in der Lage ist, über auch längere,
Minuten sogar einen Gedanken auszuführen, ohne Äh zu sagen, in einer wirklichen
rhetorischen Schärfe, dass es wirklich.
Kann ganze Sätze sprechen.
Ja, naja, die anderen sind da alle mit einem Zettel gewesen.
Ich weiß, Olaf Scholz kriegt das nicht hin.
Genau, also er warnt vor exzessiver, oder er hat was gegen exzessive Regulierung
und warnt vor einer innovationshemmenden Politik.
Und ich denke, das kann man ganz klar sagen, diese Regulierung wird potenziell
innovationshemmend sein.
Sie lehnen außerdem die Nachhaltigkeits- und die Inklusivitätsziele ab.
Surprise, surprise.
Und sie haben ja auch alles, was Hinweis auf Diversity, Equity und Inclusion
ist, wird von Regierungswebsites entfernt.
Naja, also da haben sie ja wirklich eine schockierende, also auch eine schockierend
unsinnige Innenpolitik.
Aber okay, die Innenpolitik der USA ist mir verhältnismäßig egal.
Dann sagen sie, naja, das ist dann wirtschaftliche Chancen, da haben sie Bedenken,
dass also zu starke Regulierung eben die wirtschaftlichen Möglichkeiten der
KI-Entwicklung einschränken könnte.
Und dann nochmal spezifisch energiepolitische Differenzen, weil sie sagen ja,
wenn ihr die europäischen Bestrebungen von fossilen Brennstoffen weniger abhängig
zu sein, finden sie auch bescheuert.
Das ist auch hinderlich für die Entwicklung der KI-Industrie.
Also sie haben im Prinzip gesagt, alles was man dem Ding jetzt noch in den Weg
stellt, finden wir falsch.
Und.
Darüber gibt es ja auch gerade große Diskussionen.
Ich muss auch echt sagen, dass ich es natürlich mit der Rolle,
die Europa und Deutschland in diesem Kontext dieser Entwicklung,
dieser neuen Technologie spielen,
mich auch,
eher nicht so fühle, als würde da noch was Großes entspringen.
Gleichzeitig freue ich mich natürlich schon, wenn Europa vielleicht ...
Dann doch ein paar Prinzipien hochhält, die man nicht der Innovation und dem
Markt und der Wirtschaft opfert. Wie siehst du das?
Ja, also ich meine, jetzt haben wir irgendwie, ich meine, es ist ja interessant,
also wer hat jetzt, also gut, USA lassen wir jetzt mal raus,
aber UK stimmt natürlich auch dagegen.
Da haben sie sich, das war wahrscheinlich das erste Mal, dass sie so einen kleinen
Brexit-Bonus hatten, weil sie sagen konnten, so naja, also wir sind ja nicht
in der EU und wir haben ja nicht den AI-Act irgendwie mit verfasst.
Ja, das passt dann mal, weil dieser AI-Act so, der meiner Meinung nach,
vorschnell verabschiedet wurde, Und der jetzt sozusagen alle möglichen Unternehmen
verpflichtet, irgendwie jetzt da alle möglichen Vorkehrungen zu treffen und
interne Schulungen und Trainings und so weiter.
Wahrscheinlich kein einziges Unternehmen in Europa ist in irgendeiner Form derzeit
compliant mit diesem AI-Act, der jetzt irgendwie gilt seit ein paar Tagen.
Und das ist halt, sagen wir mal, ein sehr starker Ausdruck, diesem,
so erstmal erstmal erstmal alles irgendwie regulieren, erstmal alles erstmal
begrenzen und dann ärgern wir uns, warum es keine Innovationen gibt.
Das ist so ein bisschen, also ich übertreibe es jetzt ein bisschen,
ja ich verstehe ja auch den Wunsch und in gewisser Hinsicht finde ich es auch fast schon.
Anbetungswürdig, dass man,
Und dieses professionalisierte Bedenkenträgertum da auch schon so weit vorangebracht
hat, dass man immer so, oh, wir brauchen jetzt hier irgendwie eine Regulierung dafür.
Aber wenn man halt irgendwas reguliert, bevor man es wirklich verstanden hat,
dann wird es halt schwierig.
Da den richtigen Zeitpunkt zu finden, ist sicherlich nicht einfach und diese
Veranstaltung ist offiziell der Aktionsgipfel zur künstlichen Intelligenz.
Ja, ich weiß jetzt auch nicht so ganz genau, ehrlich gesagt,
was sie sich davon versprochen haben,
da in irgendeiner Form auf so großer internationaler Ebene zu verabschieden,
weil am Ende machen ja sowieso alle, was sie wollen.
Ja, das scheint natürlich so ein bisschen der andere Gedanke dazu zu sein,
dass alle am Ende sagen, ja, legt euch mal schon Ketten an und dann gib ihm, gib ihm, gib ihm.
Wir haben ja schon gehört, die Chinesen lachen sich da wahrscheinlich kaputt.
Ja, die können sich auf jeden Fall kaputt lachen.
Es ist auf jeden Fall sehr spannend, das zu sehen, wie sich die unterschiedlichen
Staaten dieser neuen Technologie nähern.
Wir können noch eine Kleinigkeit melden.
Genau, Fälschung. Ich habe gehört, es ist eine Fälschung im Umlauf gebracht
worden von Bösewichten.
Was kannst du mir dazu erzählen?
Es gab eine Demonstration, vor einer Woche war das dann in Berlin,
eine von vielen, es gibt ja jetzt jeden Tag Demonstrationen immer noch,
die sich mit dem Rutsch in die Fremdenfeindlichkeit der Bundesrepublik Deutschland beschäftigen.
Im politischen Mainstream auseinandersetzen. Und das war eine Demonstration
der hedonistischen Internationale,
die mit Freiwillige Feuerwehr der Demokratie aufgerufen hat.
Da waren mehrere Feuerwehrautos, alle Demo-Rednerinnen hatten die Reden gespickt mit aller Hand.
Und vergleichen oder rollen aus dem Bereich der Flammenverhütung.
Und auch vor Ort war der Adenauer SRP Plus,
der Gefängnisbus, den das Zentrum für politische Schönheit ja umgebaut hat zu
einem veritablen Demo-Fahrzeug.
Und das wurde dann an Ort und Stelle beschlagnahmt und abgeschleppt.
Übrigens auch wahrscheinlich das erste Mal, dass ich ein Fahrzeug gesehen habe,
mit dem man einen Bus abschleppen kann.
Das machst du ja nicht mit einem Volvo Kombi oder so, sondern das ist dann irgendwie
ein Fahrzeug mit vier Achsen.
Das.
Und vorne ist so ein LKW-Führerhaus dran, also ein relativ großes Fahrzeug mit
entsprechender Kraft, um so einen Bus abzuschleppen.
Der fuhr dann da drunter, hebt den dann auch vorne an und hat den dann abgeschleppt.
Und dem geht voran, dass sie, und das ist dann auch wieder ein bisschen faszinierend, dass die Polizei,
Berliner Polizei, sich eine riesige Mühe gegeben hat, spezifisch dieses Fahrzeug
aus dem Verkehr zu ziehen.
Ja, da weißt du, also wenn man immer meint, Berlin, gäbe es keine Polizei oder
so, doch haben wir, die sind nur halt maßenhaft damit beschäftigt,
gegen das Zentrum für politische Schönheit vorzugehen.
Das Zentrum hat dann mal so gesagt, wie viele Kilometer die mit ihrem Bus überhaupt
fahren konnten und der wird einfach am laufenden Band von der Polizei angehalten
und sie haben ja ein Gutachten,
dass quasi sämtliche Veränderungen,
die sie an dem Fahrzeug vorgenommen haben,
von der DEKRA hat bestätigen lassen.
Und dann wurden sie, glaube ich, 30 Mal kontrolliert und so weiter.
Und jetzt hat die Polizei Berlin irgendwie ein Gegengutachten gemacht,
in dem sie dann eben quasi aus der Ferne haben feststellen lassen,
ohne das Fahrzeug zu sehen, dass sich daran irgendwelche Veränderungen gäbe,
die den Betrieb nicht erlauben und deswegen eine sofortige Stilllegung erfordern,
und das Abschleppen dieses Fahrzeugs.
Aus der Ferne haben sie das festgestellt. Wie haben sie das denn gemacht?
Aus der Ferne festgestellt.
Zoom oder was?
Na gut, dazu finde ich jetzt hier nicht so viele Infos öffentlich. Dann noch ein paar.
Nicht offizielle Infos, aber es gibt dann hier auch eine schöne Darstellung.
Die Rechtsgutachten, TÜV und Kontrollgeschichte des Adenauer SRP Plus,
wo sie dann zu jedem Kilometer zeigen, wann sie wo angehalten wurden.
Irgendwie Termine alle wahrgenommen haben und so weiter.
Es ist auf jeden Fall wirklich ein faszinierendes Beispiel für jeden, der in Berlin wohnt,
dass das ausgerechnet der Berliner Polizei doch sich so viel Mühe geben kann, etwas zu verhindern.
Und vor allem, gerade in Berlin, sagen wir mal,
sicherzustellen, dass an einem Fahrzeug alles eingetragen ist,
bis hin zu, das zu beschlagnahmen und stillzulegen.
Wenn man sich jetzt in den Berliner Straßen regelmäßig
bewegt hat man nicht den Eindruck dass da.
Jetzt irgendwie ein Schwerpunkt der polizeilichen Tätigkeit Berlins drin liegt
aber wenn man einer Künstlergruppe ein Auto mit dem sie relativ viel Aufmerksamkeit
bekommen wegnehmen kann dann sind da auf einmal ungeahnte Kräfte ein.
Bus kein Auto ein.
Bus.
Kein kleiner Bus, sondern ein richtig großer, dicker, fetter, riesiger Reisebus.
Ja, für den, und das ist ja auch das Fahrzeug, dieser Bus kommt da halt zu der Demonstration.
Die Demonstration hat gestartet in der Reinhardtstraße vor der Niederlassung
der FDP und wollte sich dann von, und hat sich dann auch von dort in Richtung
der Niederlassung der CDU bewegt.
Und da kommen die dann mit einem,
Stehen die bereit mit einem Abschleppfahrzeug für einen Bus?
Wie gesagt, den kannst du nicht mit einem Volvo-Combo abschleppen.
Da ist irgendwie ein LKW-Abschlepper.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele LKW-Abschleppfahrzeuge es in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
gibt, aber ich würde sagen, es handelt sich um eine hohe einstellige oder niedrige zweistellige Zahl.
Naja, das ist schon ein bisschen höher, weil es gibt schon eine Menge Busse.
Ja, okay, aber die LKWs, die bleiben ja auch so schnell nicht liegen.
Die haben ja genug Räder, ne? Aber okay, gut, sagen wir mal,
es gibt, aber auf jeden Fall hat nicht jeder so ein Abschleppfahrzeug.
Und die Polizei Berlin auch nicht, das haben die sich nämlich von einem Autodienst,
den ich jetzt hier nicht nennen will, haben kommen lassen, haben den bestellt.
Das wird sicherlich auch nicht so günstig sein. und dann haben sie Fotos von
dieser Aktion auf Social Media verbreitet auch das zeigt ja also ich meine,
wenn das jetzt irgendwie scheißegal wäre also die Polizei Berlin macht ja die
twittern dann da und meistens twittern die irgendwelchen Quatsch oder irgendwas
noteworthy in der Regel natürlich auch etwas das geeignet sein soll,
die Polizei in der Öffentlichkeit positiv darzustellen.
Und da haben sie dann den Abschleppvorgang getwittert mit der,
mit dem Text Während eines Einsatzes unseres A28 in Mitte wurde heute ein Bus
ohne gültige Betriebserlaubnis festgestellt.
Die vorhandenen Dokumente zur Teilnahme an öffentlichen Straßenverkehr stimmten
nicht mit dem heute festgestellten Zustand des Fahrzeugs überein.
Auch eine gemeinsam vorgenommene Durchsicht der Unterlagen und eine kurze Erörterung
der verkehrsrechtlichen Lage mit dem Verantwortlichen brachten keine Lösung.
Daher wurde der Bus durch unsere Einsatzhundertschaft,
Und die Begleitschutz- und Verkehrshundertschaft zur erneuten Erstellung eines
technischen Gutachtens im heutigen Zustand sichergestellt.
Also irgendwie offenbar zwei Hundertschaften, drei sogar, Einsatzhundertschaft,
Begleitschutzhundertschaft und Verkehrshundertschaft, also so viele waren da nicht.
Sichergestellt und mit einem riesigen Abschlussfahrzeug abgeschleppt.
Auf diesem Bild ist jetzt der Bus vom Zentrum für politische Schönheit abgebildet,
auf dem auf der Seite steht Adenauer SRP und das haben die irgendwie, wahrscheinlich mit KI,
haben sie das weg, das könnte echt mit KI gewesen sein, unglaublich was sie
da, also sie haben es sehr,
also sie haben diesen Schriftzug entfernt und den siehst du auf dem Bild jetzt nicht.
Und man fragt sich, warum? Warum haben die denn den Schriftzug entfernt?
Und auf Anfragen haben sie dann gesagt, naja, sie entfernen alle besonderen
Kennzeichen von Fahrzeugen, zum Beispiel auch Kennzeichen und sowas,
wenn sie Fotos von denen twittern.
Jetzt ist aber in dem gleichen Bild erkennbar, das Kennzeichen von dem Abschleppfahrzeug
sowie der Name des Betreibers und die Aufschrift Bergen abschleppen, Kranarbeiten,
wo man sich natürlich fragt, Wie konnte
denn das entgehen, zumal das Abschleppfahrzeug ja größer da drauf ist?
Markus Reuter hat das auf Netzpolitik.org dann nochmal behandelt,
wie man sich das denn vorstellen kann, zumal die Manipulation eben nicht gekennzeichnet ist. Ja.
Keine Ahnung, für sowas haben die Zeit. Für sowas haben wir Zeit, Tim.
Das ist schon wirklich krass.
Sie haben dann ein sichtbar verpixeltes Foto auf X gepostet.
Allerdings ist weiterhin, das Originalbild haben sie gelassen.
Genau, sagen wir verpixeln grundsätzlich Kennzeichen, Firmennamen und Schriftzüge
auf Fahrzeugen in polizeilichen Maßnahmen. Ja, gut.
Der Autodienst mit seinen Bergen abschleppenden Kranarbeiten,
Der ist denn da vor lauter Mühe, diesen Schriftzug von dem Adenauer SRP,
der auch noch kleiner im Bild ist, zu entfernen,
dann offenbar ist er ihnen entgangen.
Technisch haben sie sich schon ein bisschen Mühe gegeben. Also wenn man weiß,
dass da der Schriftzug drauf ist, dann weiß man halt es falsch.
Weiß man, an welcher Stelle das ist? Vor allem, weil da die Spiegelung ist,
aber das ist schon wirklich...
Ja doch, wenn man jetzt den Kontrast und die Helligkeit aufreißt,
merkt man, ich glaube, das ist keine KI, das war schon von Hand.
Erkennt man die Feld?
Ich habe es herausgefunden, ich habe es nachgewiesen.
Mit einer MI, die haben das mit einer MI gemacht?
Die ja extrem zuverlässig sein soll, habe ich gehört.
Gleichzeitig gibt das Zentrum für politische Schönheit auch mal an,
wie viele Einsätze dieses Fahrzeugs sie,
verpasst haben. 16.1. in Hamburg, 18.1. in Chemnitz, 22.1.
In Leonberg, 24.1. in Siegen-Weidenau, 25.1. in Halle-Saale.
Ja, also immer quasi durch irgendwelche ausgedehnten polizeilichen Kontrollen,
mehrere Stunden Kontrolle.
Wahnsinn.
Warum nur?
Fahrt nach Berlin. Kontrolle durch Verkehrshundert schafft der Berliner Polizei eine Stunde.
Untersagung der Demonstrationsteilnahme. Polizist sagt, eure Grundrechte sind mir egal.
Dann durften sie weiterfahren, aber nur fünf Kilometer.
Danach erneut eine Stunde Kontrolle mit dem Ergebnis alles in bester Ordnung.
Geil.
Dann waren sie erneut beim TÜV. Über die Dachreling auf Wunsch der Abteilung 5 der Polizei Berlin.
Siebter Zweiter, Eintragung aller Änderungen bei der Zulassungsstelle.
Neunter Zweiter, Abteilung 5, genau die, deren Gutachten und Wünsche explizit
erfüllt wurden, kommt in den Bus und teilt ohne weitere Untersuchungen mit,
dass das Fahrzeug jetzt beschlagnahmt wird.
Das war vor einer Woche ist der jetzt noch beschlagnahmt?
Nach meiner Wahrnehmung schon.
Man merkt auf jeden Fall, die
hedonistische Internationale ist auf jeden Fall ein Stachel im Fleisch.
Und das muss man immer wirklich mal zugute halten. Aber ich muss sagen,
ich habe wenig Verständnis für das Verhalten der Polizei.
Also ich meine, da gibt es wirklich genug Probleme, mit denen man sich jetzt
mal so intensiv beschäftigen könnte.
Wie zum Beispiel so Harzis aber es muss dann irgendwie gegen diese Aktionskünstler gehen,
weil das kann ja nicht sein das ist einfach Banana Republic mäßig Da.
Könnte man den Eindruck gewinnen, dass die Aufmerksamkeit der Verkehrshunderschaft
Abteilung 5 Polizei Berlin,
sich nicht gleichmäßig und unvoreingenommen über den Berliner Straßenverkehr erstreckt.
Das wäre jetzt so, der Verdacht steht im Raum.
Der steht definitiv im Raum, der Verdacht. Gut, Linus, lass uns ein Ende finden.
Wir hatten ja noch den KI-Gipfel als kleines Ablenkungsthema drin,
damit sich die Leute nicht wieder beschweren.
Wir hätten nicht über Netzpolitik gesprochen.
Hammer, nicht. Ist richtig. Ist aber nichts passiert. Wir haben keine Regierung.
Und am Sonntag Wahl. Am Sonntag ist Wahl. 23. Februar ist Wahl.
Wählt jemanden,
der nicht mit Klammerbeule gepudert hat.
Das wäre ganz gut. Ich wollte auch noch mal was zu sagen zu diesen Einlassungen,
die ja immer wieder kommen.
Ja, Netzpolitik und konzentriert euch doch mal so auf eure Kernthemen und so.
Ich weiß, das Netzpolitik, das steht hier so im Titel und damit beschäftigen wir uns auch viel,
aber es ist nicht das Einzige, wozu wir uns Gedanken machen und im Wesentlichen
teilen wir hier unsere Gedanken zum Geschehen der Welt.
Das ist ein bisschen schade, dass wir da keinen more catchy Name gefunden haben,
aber das war halt nun mal der Arbeitstitel, mit dem wir jetzt irgendwie schon
so lange laufen und mal gucken.
Vielleicht feilen wir da auch nochmal dran, aber man muss sich da jetzt nicht
so festlegen, weil wir sind irgendwie ja nicht nur Experten in Netzpolitik,
sondern überhaupt einfach generell Experten, oder? Linus?
Ich bin generell Experte. Der einer der wenigen Universalgelehrten des Landes bin ich.
Ich bin nur Spezialexperte.
Was da gerne mit rausklingt und dass dieser Anwurf.
Sagt man nichts zu dem Thema? Da klingt natürlich immer drin,
also der kommt ja eigentlich nur,
wenn wir uns in dieser Sendung beispielsweise zu Migrationspolitik äußern oder
Kritik an den Positionen der AfD oder der CDU in diesem Bereich vornehmen.
Es kommt ja nicht, wenn wir über irgendwas anderes sprechen.
Es kommt primär dann. Sicherlich wird es auch wieder eine Ausnahme geben,
die die Regel bestätigt, aber das bestätigt mir wiederum,
dass wir auch unter unseren Hörerinnen Menschen haben, die gelinde gesagt vielleicht
migrationskritisch eingestellt sind.
Und die sich dann auf den Schlips getreten fühlen, wenn wir beispielsweise,
wie es mir ein Anliegen ist, in dieser Sendung darauf aufmerksam machen,
dass der Bereich der Migrationspolitik in Deutschland sicherlich mit Problemen
behaftet ist, wir aber gerade ganz andere Probleme haben,
und vor allem sicherlich nicht eure Situation und das, was ihr in eurem Leben zu beklagen habt,
auf die Migrationspolitik zurückzuführen ist.
Wenn du nicht genug hast, liegt es selten daran, dass jemand anderes,
der noch weniger hat, als du es dir weggenommen hat.
Es liegt in der Regel daran, dass das Geld irgendwo nach oben wegdiffundiert
ist und nicht nach unten.
Und deswegen betonen wir das hier regelmäßig, weil eine Verzerrung der politischen
Wahrnehmung in diesem Bereich, an allem ist jetzt der Ausländer schuld,
nicht der Situation gerecht wird und auch nicht zu vernünftigen Wahrnehmungen
oder zu vernünftigen Lösungen führen wird.
Und dann treten wir euch eben auf den Schlips und dann kann ich mir vorstellen,
dass man sagt, die sollen sich auf ihre eigenen Themen konzentrieren,
damit ich mich nicht, damit nicht vielleicht eine andere Glaubenshaltung,
die ich habe, hier in Frage gestellt wird.
Und den Gewalt werden wir euch nicht tun.
Genau. So, jetzt ist aber Schluss. Leute, viel Spaß. Wählt mal schön.
Egal, wie es ausgeht, das Leben geht weiter.
Könnte stürmisch werden, aber schauen wir mal, was so passiert.
Bist du auf einer Wahlparty? Ich bin auf einer Wahlparty eingeladen.
Was gibt es denn zu feiern? Ich habe hier so eine Einladung zu einer Wahlparty
bekommen und habe gefragt, was gibt es zu feiern?
Eine Ahnung.
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Vielleicht werden wir ja sehen, was es zu feiern gibt.
Also unter Umständen,
Den Nicht-Einzug des BSW.
Zum Beispiel.
Und den Nicht-Einzug der FDP. Das wären,
potenzielle Partys in der B-Note.
Gut, bevor wir jetzt aber hier zu parteipolitisch werden und uns nicht ausreichend
über den möglichen Einzug anderer
Parteien gefreut haben, machen wir jetzt wirklich immer den Deckel drauf.
Wir sagen Tschüss. Bis bald.
Bis bald.